[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans le skyco le
magazine qui vous raconte l'actualité
économique du territoire de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines nous partirons
à la rencontre de Thierry Clicquot de
manque directeur commercial chez
districtom il nous parle de leur
ambition à rendre accessible
l'impression 3D au plus grand nombre
décryptage sur initiative Saint-Quentin
en Yvelines ce dispositif propose chaque
année cinquantaine de près d'honneur
pour accompagner les porteurs de projets
et enfin nous partirons à la rencontre
de Morgane breband le directeur général
de l'entreprise expect spécialisé dans
les batteries de véhicule
[Musique]
bienvenue chez DISTRICOM nous sommes
imprimeurs numériques grand format avec
une société créée il y a 18 ans par
Frédéric Fernandez
[Musique]
l'historique de distrium c'est quoi la
base on est imprimé en numérique grand
format assez naturellement on est venu
sur des éléments un peu plus 2D et 3D
avec le polystyrène que vous pouvez voir
derrière moi autant sur des éléments 2D
pour des logos ça fonctionne très bien
sur du polystyrène autant des moments
qu'on veut aller vers des personnages ou
des factices de produits la 3D en
impression pure devient absolument
indispensable on va aller voir
directement avec Guillaume notre
graphiste comment on prépare la
fabrication derrière
[Musique]
alors on va être capable de le mettre en
situation soit dans un environnement
fictif soit dans un environnement réel
avec des gens par exemple à côté puisque
la taille humaine permet bien se rendre
compte de la taille de l'objet à partir
de ces éléments là ça va générer en fait
un fichier d'impression qui va donner
des informations à l'imprimante et c'est
surtout avec ces éléments là qu'on va
savoir le temps d'impression qu'on a
on est arrivé dans l'atelier où vous
voyez derrière moi les deux imprimantes
3D très grand format qui ont pu arriver
chez nous grâce à l'accompagnement de
l'État et plus particulièrement le plan
France relance qui nous a subventionné à
hauteur de 500000 euros sur l'ensemble
de nos investissements à la fois sur la
partie 3D mais également sur
l'impression plus classique en 2D
François a été très important pour nous
dans notre accélération parce que cet
accompagnement qui est qui s'appuyait
sur un plan d'action sur plusieurs
années vient asseoir en fait cette
possibilité d'être en avance
technologiquement parlant elle est en
train de poser correctement la matière
les lampes UV qui sont en fait la
technologie qui permettent de
polymériser le gel vont s'allumer pour
le figer en fait donc là si on veut voir
le résultat de l'impression
ce qui est intéressant dans cette
machine c'est de voir la dimension
puisque on peut imprimer un mètre 80
d'un seul tenant donc techniquement je
peux presque rentrer dans la machine si
on devait m'imprimer en un seul tenant
debout comme ça faudrait 12 heures
d'impression qui est extrêmement rapide
la taille des pièces qui pourrait
rentrer dans l'imprimante ne sont pas la
limite de la machine on peut aussi
imprimer des pièces énormes une énorme
mascotte de 10 mètres de haut et on va
juste l'imprimer par segment en fait et
après on va l'assembler mettre une
finition là où en fait dans la plupart
des métiers de l'industrie de
l'impression 3D les gens et leur faut
des fermes entières en fait d'imprimante
3D pour imprimer justement des éléments
et faire après du volume nous on a
besoin de qu'une seule parce qu'elle
peut imprimer vite grand et après par
assemblage on fait des grands morceaux
[Musique]
dans ce décryptage nous allons nous
intéresser à initiative Sky mais
qu'est-ce que c'est initiative sky
[Musique]
il s'agit de financer quoi
mais comment faire pour obtenir les
fonds
[Musique]
d'où viennent ces fonds
et combien de prêts ont-ils déjà été
accordés
initiative Sky c'est aussi une équipe de
conseillers pour l'élaboration d'un
business plan et ce sont aussi des
parents qui donnent leur retour
d'expérience au futur manager
[Musique]